I think that we're here to honor the
legacy of a studio the legacy of a
family the landless that and the legacy
of the craftsmen and artists that gave
birth to what I think is the modern
horror film this man took the visual
tradition of expressionist films and not
only updated but transformed it into
what we now understand to be the basics
of what a horror film should be today's
film is for me extremely important Bride
of Frankenstein the first one we're
going to see I recommend the whole
series if you're a monster kid and I am
my mother is here to attest to that I I
think that we find out that the films we
love are truly emotional biographies and
partially prophecies of who we are and
who we can be and this is also true of
the men who made them and if the first
one was about the essential loneliness
of man and meltonian episode about being
thrusted into a world that you didn't
create and didn't understand and the
second one is the absolute compulsion
for company the need not to be alone and
through the movie we will see the
monster try that companionship with
different figures that either adopt him
or rejecting in different terms and
ultimately the most beautiful act the
most profound act the monster can do
which is acquiring his first choice
during his first will decision which
leads to the immortal words we belong
dead that is the first time the monster
is not just victim of circumstance or
thrown around by the world that he
doesn't understand is the first time he
stands tall and tells the world what he
needs to be what he wants to be
tonight's movie is a very special film
because of the clash
many talents James whale who was an
incredible visual astern and incredible
director in in every respect but who was
also cynical and called sometimes far
more removed from emotion in many of his
movies he had an almost entomological
view of mankind in some of his other
horror movies but he is palliated by the
incredible talents of Boris Karloff who
understands like whale what it is to be
an outsider since he had in him foreign
blood that was in his own biography a
very hard legacy to carry in in in in
his native England whale also understood
that on him in many ways rejected
Karloff in some manner because he saw
himself in him and Karloff found an a
great ally in Jack piers
Jack Pierce is a mythic makeup artist
and in my opinion the one that gives
birth to what we understand as the
modern makeup artist a legacy that has
been passed to the dicks made Rick Baker
Robo teen William total John Chambers
many many many others
he created the monster with exacting
attention to detail and the variations
but he does between the first creature
makeup and the second are astonishing
especially if you think of the medium
and the resources he has the creature
also evolves through the film and his
look grows and grows to represent the
journey and the where I think of Karloff
and the creature through the film and
the beautiful moment at the end which in
some ways address the Bride of
Frankenstein almost as the cold uncaring
future and the creature as the past
trying to connect that moment in which
the creature understands what Sartre
said so beautiful that he'll is others
is only aided by Pierce's creation a
perfect score perfect cinematography and
in many many other ways
just a perfect movie gives birth to this
beautiful cycle that I hope you enjoy
doing the week and not just come for the
big hits but see also the last
well-known films I for me is an
incredibly important movie because I
been a misfit and a freak of a very
large size all my life and the moment I
discovered the creature I discovered in
him a twin soul and in his suffering and
in his disfranchisement emotionally I
found a kindred spirit